today I listen to my dating coach she
said you do not get your expectation you
get your minimum standard
is your dating coach married yes because
she has a baby and her wedding ring is
at least five carats yeah but and her
man is rich she doesn't even have to
work okay yourself makes like 30 to 50
Grand a month coaching women in love
I mean good luck if that like works for
you I just like to me that sounds like
a 200k engagement ring like I think like
guys are gonna hear that and be like no
no no you don't have to have the man
who's okay with maintaining you
right with maintaining you right like
you can be high maintenance but if you
are dating a man that is okay with
maintaining you you're fine you're not
high maintenance then you're just on
their level